go figure the reality is is that people
in the trenches don't need to wait for
research even though this is now finally
becoming in Fab
this is something that's been a reality
for me for the last 25 years the reason
for this video is for a lot of you
there's a lot of things you believe in
that pop culture mainstream media
Society other humans haven't bought into
yet as you go into 2023 lean into the
[ __ ] that you believe in when I was all
about this life in the late 90s early
2000s people said that were close to me
nobody knew who the [ __ ] I was but
people around me were like no businesses
you got to be rough and tough and like
nice guys finish last and you're going
to be soft you're going to lose and I
used to [ __ ] laugh at these [ __ ]
in the back of my head because I always
just knew I knew and a lot of you know a
lot of stuff right now that isn't common
practice things that I and others don't
have a clue about lean into your
intuition believe in what you see day to
day and execute on it